Hand washing should take you about one minute.
Use a timer or count from 1 to 10 in each of the following steps.
Wet hands with water and apply enough soap to cover all surfaces of the hands.
Let the water run smoothly to avoid touching the tap later on.
Rub hands palm to palm to obtain a good quantity of foam.
Then rub right palm over the back of left hand with interlaced fingers and vice versa.
Rub again palm to palm with fingers interlaced.
Rub the back of your fingers to opposing palms with fingers interlocked,
repeating this action for each hand.
Rub rotationally left thumb clasped in right palm and vice versa.
To clean the tips of the fingers, rub rotationally backwards and forwards
with clasped fingers of right hand in left palm and vice versa.
Rinse hands thoroughly with running water.
Dry hands thoroughly with a single use towel.
If the tap is not elbow operated, use this towel to turn off the tap without touching it directly.
Your hands are now clean and safe.